au délit de a à z traiteur à montigny le
bretonneux les semaines n'ont aucun
secret ces crêpes originaires du maghreb
peuvent être salée sucrée garni que
nature la gérante nous dévoile sa
recette et pour cinq ou six semaines il
faut un kilo de farine 14 grammes de sel
et 7 100 millilitres d'eau va poser sa
farine dans un petit saladier et ensuite
vous allez mélanger le sel est petit à
petit vous à les incorporer les sept
cent millilitres d'eau une hotte y est
dit de façon à pouvoir apporter un peu
de douceur et de chaleur à cette date là
il faut continuer de malaxer le tout
pour des gazéifiée la pâte
le but qu'elles deviennent élastique il
faut ensuite la laisser reposer pendant
15 à 30 minutes
ensuite on va former des petites buttes
qu'on va caresser légèrement avec un
petit peu de villes de tournesol vient
le moment d'ouvrir la petite boule de
pâte en l'étalant sur un plan de travail
et en y ajoutant au fur et à mesure un
mélange d'huile de beurre et un peu de
semoule il faut ensuite replié les côtés
les uns après les autres au fur à mesure
les quatre côtés vont être repliés vers
l'intérieur ceci va former un directeur
ou un petit carré vous allez ensuite les
mettre à cuire à peu près de chaque côté
une minute une minute et demie il ne
reste plus qu'à déguster line semaine
bon appétit